the addition to be another good news for
the families of the victims from what
you just said about the AFP interviewing
earlier that an hour ago the president
of the Greek committee of aviation
security saying the deborah's might not
belong to an aircraft this is
contradicting what we had from Egypt air
the airline earlier today about four
hours ago now saying that they had found
the wreckage of the missing aircraft ms
804 near the Greek island of karpathos
now of course the investigation is still
underway we should hear more the French
and Egyptian authorities are
collaborating with the Greek authorities
in order to really identify where this
wreckage is and whether they can find
the black boxes that should give us more
information about the causes of this
accident caroleen we noted earlier that
authorities are not ruling out terrorism
what leads them to believe that that
might in fact be the case so technically
there are several things the the first
one is at the the thing that cannot be
ruled out is a device on board a small
bomb that could have been activated on
board and create decompression of the
aircraft where the aircraft could have
just come apart when when they were
flying the fact that they are not ruling
out a terrorist attack really comes from
the fact that the Egyptian military did
not receive and distressed message and
even if both engines if you want our
failing while plane is still in the air
this still gives some time for any pilot
to a glide for a little bit longer and
send this kind of distress message this
is why both the French and the Egyptian
authorities are saying at the moment
that we cannot rule out a terrorist
attack and the Egyptian Civil Aviation
is there even said that the possibility
of the terror attack is actually more
likely than a technical issue